he was here to make a difference
his humanity goofiness and politeness
are some of the attributes highlighted
by his comrades emile antoine rawasserwa
was killed in action july 18th in riyfka
30 soldiers from his unit were trying to
hold back a russian advance on the
village in eastern ukraine
he and three others were killed while
trying to help a wounded soldier we just
took so much incoming fire it was
mortars artillery
tanks shooting at us and everything at
once
so yeah we were expecting
more of us to go that day the village
didn't fall but the deadly mission
resulted in several members terminating
their contracts with ukrainian armed
forces four of my best friends
is died despite the losses
many maintain their resolve
i'm going to stay here to the end of my
life or
to the end of the war when global news
met up with some of the soldiers who
took part in the mission they had just
held a service for an american who was
killed
oscar left the hospital to attend the
memorial talking about the tragic day
with an ivy catheter still in his left
hand they are heroes
and i love them and i remember them and
they died like soldiers
global affairs canada is aware of cerro
and is working with the family his
remains are currently in nepro and once
canada provides the right documentation
they'll be transported here to key for
small service
and then shipped home in a statement to
global news his mother wrote in part
today emil antoine would surely wish
that the world understood by virtue of
his actions the importance of returning
to more human values i'm sorry that i
could not
save
her son ruslan was one of the men who
went back to the field to retrieve the
quebecer's body as one of the commanding
officers for the international fighters
he says the man they called beaver was
special
big handsome soft power you know kind of
yeah and really we miss him ciroi came
to ukraine to join the fight in march
he was 31 years old
crystal gamansen global news
keefe